[Musik]
Liebes Tagebuch, was für eine großartige Woche, ich habe
die Mexikaner und die Muslime angepisst, es war
so großartig,
diese dumme alte Dame aus England, nicht
einmal die Königin, sie kam, um mich zu sehen, also
weiß ich nicht, warum ich sie an der Hand gepackt
habe  war fantastisch,
Dienstag hatte einen sehr seltsamen Anruf aus
Deutschland. Dieser Typ sagte, er sei der deutsche
Bundeskanzler, was ist das traurige,
oh, und ich hatte einen enormen Erfolg. Ich habe
einen Terroristen festgenommen
seit dem Hitlertiger
Metzger was für ein Versager
total überbewertet und schau ich kann einen
Penis malen toll bestes Penisbild ever
okay das ist große Sache gutes Wochenende
[Applaus]